la polka la polka roi de charles trenet
voulez vous danser marquise voulez vous
danser le plus vert vous serez vite
conquise
donnez-moi lama s'il vous plaît à quelle
cadence a à aa
le menu est celle la polka du roi
pendant que le match après la pause il a
misé sur buttes paf lui et sur votre
bouche vers meilleur mois pour l'amour
je suis toujours à aa en transe en danse
quelqu'un danseurs de menus et c'est la
polka du roi montons sans faire de
tapage tout en tension le menu est la
houle montons jusqu'au troisième étage
la du bonheur nous aurons bientôt à un
aaa en transe en danse ragga la cadette
aa c'est la polka du repas aux 12 et moi
minute par m
c'est dans la joie la soie et puis le
satin que j'accomplis mon plus beau rêve
marquise je vous poste
c'est le cas du roi qui at il martelé
je ne vous sent plus très bien dans mes
bras vous sondez comme une hantise
exclu y est on a à a
dans ce cadre le menu est celle à
voltaire du roi hélas ce monsieur n est
en cire et nous nous sommes au musée
grévin louis xiv en 2003 nous ne sommes
plus des humains
finie la danse eu plus de cas dans ce
cas
ainsi s'achève la polka du roi